bonsoir philippe rogué merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france où les
tout d'abord ont fait réagir sur ce
chiffre qui est tombée dans la soirée
plus de 30000 qu'un même plus de 31000
cas de contamination en 24 heures c'est
un record depuis novembre alors qu'on
nous disait la semaine dernière que ça
allait plutôt mieux qu est ce qui s'est
passé en une semaine il s'est passé ce
qui devait se passer c'est à dire le
variés anglais est en train de gagner du
terrain il est à 95% à dunkerque et nous
noie on par séquençage on le trouve à
34% à lille il va augmenter va être à 50
% à la fin de la semaine
donc il est 30% plus contagieux et
entraîne des risques plus importants
être à l'hôpital
il se passe ce que nous disait au
gouvernement depuis longtemps et que il
a pas envie d'entendre
donc j ai peut-être même monsieur
maquereau a fait une raison il ya trois
semaines ne pas faire le confinement
mais s'il croit que l'on va y ait
échappé à ce qui devait arriver baril a
tort parce que ça va vraiment rêver
emmanuel mâcon n'est pas le seul à parce
que c'est vrai que les français n'ont
pas franchement envie d'être reconfirmer
sérieusement il ya vraiment une
inquiétude nous y sommes il faut agir
vite et bien ou c'est déjà en quelque
sorte trop tard pour vous moi j'ai pas
du tout envie d'être confiné comme tout
le monde et comme vous probablement
simplement je vois ce qui se passe à
dunkerque
dunkerque on est à 90 % au moins de
varier anglais les hôpitaux sont
complètement saturé il ya la moitié des
patients qui est qu'ils sont envoyés
ailleurs totalement au chu de lille où
il ya encore de la place mais pour
combien de temps et ils sont à un taux
d'incidence qui énorme qui à peu près
celui et le maximum qu'on a vu en france
était à 1100 c'était à roubaix au moins
de novembre donc oui on est dans une
situation extrêmement extrêmement
extrêmement difficile je pense qu'on a
eu raison de faire quelque chose à
dunkerque je pense qu'ensuite on fera la
même chose dont le reste des autres
france et puis ensuite dans les régions
où c'est aussi très difficile
on peut le regretter mais ça va être
bien entendu je vais le regretter
énormément en tant que citoyen il en
tant que médecin je vois bien la
difficulté alors qu'ils progressent
c'est vrai qu'on parle de re confiné
confinement enfin on oubliait un petit
peu vite un aussi les journalistes
bêtement on parle de confinement ont
fait en oublie quand même qu'on est
confinée depuis des semaines on couvre
feu et que là il s'agit d'un confinement
le week-end alors est ce que c'est
vraiment efficace ces petites touches à
droite à gauche le week-end alors on
aura droit de travailler c'est super
mais est ce que ça va faire baisser
vraiment le virus de confiner le week
end
la réponse telle qu'on l'a vu dans
d'autres pays un nom en angleterre ils
ont fait un confinement beaucoup plus
important ils ont ils ont fermé les
écoles mais fille qui habite là peuvent
pas aller se voir les unes les autres et
il a fallu plusieurs mois pour que ça
diminue enfin pour se débarrasse des
variés anglais et on l'a réussi parce
que il vaccine cinq fois plus qu'en
france
donc la situation française est vraiment
inquiétante alors elle est pas pareil
dans en bretagne par rapport à dunkerque
eu certes mais je pense que dans trois
semaines quatre semaines variés anglais
ce sera le variant français et ensuite
il y aura d'autres aux anomalies qui
vont apparaître dans ma vie génétique
il va falloir surveiller maintenant
est-ce qu'il faut confiné c'est très
difficile parce que sans vaccination
très importante et c'est là où on est
vraiment vraiment un problème par
rapport à l'angleterre aux états unis ou
israël ou de certains autres pays
ça va être très difficile de sortir
facilement du confinement
alors c'est vrai qu'en plus il ya les
enfants qui vont revenir à l'école à
laon nous sommes en période de vacances
scolaires on nous promet des tests
salivaires c
et c'est suffisant pour pas trop
propager ce variant anglais qu'on dit
très contagieux y compris chez les
jeunes
le test salivaire ça fait neuf mois que
mes amis de france baissent le demandons
enfin on va les avoir ça va simplifier
un petit peu les choses
ça va permettre de diagnostiquer des
gens qui sinon c'est et rustique et pas
ça va partir en changer fondamentalement
le le problème le problème c'est si on
était dans une situation idéale
on fera un confinement très serré et un
qu'on veut et en même temps à
vaccination très important mais on n'est
pas capable de faire des vaccinations
très importante donc on sait très bien
que si on fait un confinement serré ça
changera pas fondamentalement les choses
donc on est dans une situation vivre
avec le virus plutôt que les ridicules
alors il ya un cycle qui nous est
parvenue aujourd'hui par la bouche du
ministre de la santé une moyenne d'âge
qui baissent de 2,7 ans manifestement à
l'hôpital vous parliez vaccination c'est
l'incidence heureuse des premières
vaccinations en france est la preuve que
la vaccination marche
c'est la preuve définitive on a eu la
même chose en en angleterre ou en israël
mais en france ça marche il ya à peu
près pas 40% des mains des morts de kobe
qui sont dans les ehpad et zepa de 6 à 7
750 une personne seulement mais un tiers
des morts ont au minimum maintenant 80 %
des patients des personnes d épargne
forcée au mois une injection et vous
voyez que c'est très efficace puisque la
mortalité des ehpad diminue
extraordinairement donc oui ça marche
vraie question c'est comment se fait-il
que l'europe n'a pas été capable de
vacciner les européens alors en même
temps que les anglais eux mêmes les
américains ça c'est un autre débat on
aurait pas assez de temps pour l'évoquer
ici autre chiffre
stéphane fait le pardon philippe froguel
7% des adultes de plus de 20 ans dans
l'hexagone ont été infectées par le col
vide entre le début de la pandémie lé 16
février c'est l'institut pasteur qu'il
dit est ce que c'est un chiffre dont on
peut tirer des enseignements au
finalement ça veut rien dire à partir du
moment où l'immunité d'ailleurs et des
très loin de de ce chiffre la dignité
collective et qu'en plus on peut
peut-être attraper le combine une
seconde fois où ça peut quand même nous
dire quelque chose de plaisant c'est un
résultat parmi d'autres parce que c'est
c'est un peu aléatoire en mesure certes
un certain andy corps il peut y avoir
d'autres types d'immunité bon disons
qu'on a entre 20 et 30% de la population
qui a rencontré déjà le virus que celle
c'est pas l'immunité collective
si on arrive à limiter collective va
falloir vacciner entre 50 et 60% de la
population et tout le monde sait bien
que les promesses du président balle ce
que valent les promesses et que alors
corps en angleterre tout le monde sera à
peu près vacciner au mois de juin mais
deux filles même qu'à 24 ans et et 32
ans ont été vaccinés
dimanche dernier combien de jeunes
enfants sont vaccinés à l'âge de 30 ans
aucun et donc ça c'est un problème si
l'angleterre en totalité et vaccinés et
que l'europe ne l'est pas ça va être
compliqué pour les britanniques de de se
maintenir en sécurité néanmoins les
frontières vont être heureuses on va
avoir des énormes problèmes on sera
parmi les plus mauvais en france sur le
taux de gens vaccinés ce qui veut dire
que voir des problèmes pour les
touristes aussi problème pour les
français pour les pour les étrangers
vont exiger probablement des passeports
de vaccination ont les anglais oui il
peut y avoir quelque chose
tout dépend de type de virus qu'on leur
en france si et si on a des mutants qui
résiste aux vaccinations antérieures
effectivement il faut surtout pas que
les anglais viennent
si on n'a que des encore que des virus
qui circule en france qui sont contrôlés
par la vaccination ça sera correct pour
les anglais merci philippe froguel en
tout cas d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france généticien professeur au
chu de lille et adam perial collège de
londres à merci d'avoir été en direct up